Nunca pensé que El Salvador tenía tanto por ofrecer.
Tiene un montón por ofrecer
y en el día de hoy me encuentro haciendo una cosa
que me habéis pedido que haga
una reacción del vídeo de 30 cosas que quizás
no conozco sobre El Salvador.
El Salvador
es el país más pequeño del América continental,
con una superficie similar a la de Belice.
Yo pensaba que Belice era el más pequeño
y ahora nos dice el vídeo
que El Salvador es un poco más pequeño.
No lo sabía la verdad.
O sea que a pesar de ser un país tan pequeño,
tiene muchísima población.
¿Me estás diciendo no?
El Salvador tiene dentro de su territorio un total de
360 ríos. Algunos de ellos son usados para el a.
360 ríos es un montón.
Para un país tan pequeño es un montón de ríos,
no los tamales,
las canoas de plátano,
las riguas, las enchiladas,
el salpicón, la quesadilla, los elotes locos,
el casamiento, el atol chuco y las excusas,
el casamiento y el atol chuco y las pupusas. Cómo no,
las pupusas. Me encantan las pupusas.
El monumento al divino Salvador del mundo
está ubicado en San Salvador.
Aquí he estado yo en la plaza de las Américas.
Este monumento he estado aquí.
Está compuesto por la figura de Cristo, superbonito.
Es impresionante. Este sitio me encantó.
Yo solo recuerdo que tenía muchísimo calor.
Hacía muchísimo calor en San Salvador.
Es de las pocas cosas que conocí
de la capital salvadoreña,
el el monumento del Salvador del mundo,
pero sí, me encantó mucho y quisiera regresar de nuevo.
Me ha encantado el vídeo
sobre las curiosidades del Salvador.
Había muchísimas cosas que no sabía,
qué sitios tan bonitos.
¡Por favor! Dan ganas de ir a vivir incluso ahí.
O sea, no solo visitar sino vivir en aquel paraíso.
O sea, es un paraíso esto.
Nunca pensé que El Salvador tenía tanto por ofrecer,
tiene un montón por ofrecer